i'm dr ugori roku a board-certified
gastroenterologist and digestive disease
specialist today i'll be answering your
questions from twitter this is gut
support
[Music]
queer republican how long is a small and
large intestine because that's how many
feet per second food moves through my
body so the small intestine is about 18
feet long the large intestine is about
six feet long oftentimes people will eat
food and feel like it's running straight
through their body but it turns out that
there is a process called the
gastrocolic reflex that's probably
accounting for that immediate bowel
movement you have what is that it's when
your stomach senses that this food
coming in and wants to create space in
the body so it tells the colon move
things along through the process of
peristalsis it relaxes the muscles at
the bottom of your anus and you are able
to poop and so the poop you're pooping
out is not the food you just ate it
typically takes about two to three days
for you to eat a food and actually have
it leave your body you should know that
at king of kgn aren't we all a little
lactose intolerant the answer king is no
just you but just kidding uh a lot of us
become lactose intolerant over time the
whole concept is that we're all born
typically with enzymes called lactase
that help us digest breast milk and so
as we get older oftentimes many people
in the population lose their ability to
break down that dairy it happens more
commonly in african-american communities
american indian communities asian
communities latino communities and that
makes us more intolerant to dairy daily
issues
98 my poop is dark green like the color
of spinach am i dying the color of poop
starts off as being green for everybody
and that's just the color of the pigment
bile as bile makes its way through your
digestive tract it's oxidized it's
digested by the time it comes out it's
the poop that you normally come to know
and love of a brown color the green
color in poop is not a sign of anything
dangerous but that green it's all coming
from you you're probably just having a
faster motility movement of the poop
through your body that's letting you
still be able to see that green color
that you normally wouldn't see two boobs
and a toot this person needs a
gastroenterologist badly if you hold all
your farts in do you start floating away
like a balloon obviously the answer is
no if you were to hold all your farts in
uh you would be a very uncomfortable
person there would be a high
likelihood of gas incontinence so
likelihood that you would indeed let one
rip at some point with some movement but
after a while gas being gas just finds a
way to dissipate from one area and go to
another area if it finds it's not able
to go out through the anus like it
usually can it'll dissipate into your
body and find its way excreted out your
body perhaps through your respiratory
system or through another method so to
make the distinction between the anus
and the sphincter i can show you on our
little diagram here the anus pretty much
refers to this entire area that includes
a number of supportive tissue and
muscles it's the thing right at the end
of your digestive system now as part of
your anus you have sphincters external
internal that help to tighten the bottom
of your anus to make sure that nothing
escapes so pretty much the sphincter are
those muscles that exist within the anus
to help prevent incontinence of gas
liquids or solids and what is
incontinence doctor incontinence just
means that you're letting things rip
without intending to sometimes people
have gas incontinence they're passing
gas without meaning to or they could
actually have poop incontinence we're
actually having you know bowel movements
at moments you just didn't plan on
having those not fun
twin cities chick asks how long does it
take for you to get food poisoning after
having eaten something suspect asking
for a fr okay no
that's bull i'm asking for myself
concerned emoji face and so it turns out
that when you eat something that makes
you sick we call that food poisoning it
can happen pretty quickly within an hour
you can have toxins that have been
formed by the bacteria affecting your
gut bacteria like be serious found in
items like fried foods or clostridium
found in dented cans that can have
toxins that are infiltrated in the food
can make you sick again within an hour
or two there's some that take a couple
of days to develop but you might be
running for the toilet bowl even before
you're done with your plate simply
thinking what is a gastroenterologist
and why do commercials talk about them
like we should all have one so a
gastroenterologist is a physician who
spent six years after med school
training on digestive disease health
oftentimes you need to see us for many
reasons 20 million americans have
chronic gastrointestinal diseases like
ibs or ibd one of the most common
procedures that we do as
gastroenterologists is the colonoscope
and this is where we look with the
camera into your colon and look for any
signs of any disease or polyps that need
to be removed and just in case you are
feeling comfortable i'm going to show
you exactly what we do during your
kaleidoscope so what i have here
is
uh one of our enteroscopes in particular
this is designed to look into your
upper abdomen but a similar process we
use for a colomoscope so it has a couple
of dials that allows me to
drive
the scope as it makes its way through
your intestines it has a light source
that lets me have a good look and look
to look for polyps or any sign of
disease it has a few channels through
the scope that allows me to take samples
with the biopsy forceps and it also has
clips that let me stop bleeding or
cauterize and burn any bleeding sites if
necessary next up mucosal immunology are
there really 10 times more bacteria than
cells in our body mucosal if i can call
you that the answer is probably not the
10 times number comes from earlier on in
our examination of the microbiome so the
collection of bacteria viruses and fungi
that exist in our gut and the estimation
at the time was that there was 10 times
more
microbiota than there were actually
human cells that number has been revised
recently especially when you're just
looking at bacteria it's thought to be
more that for every one human cell you
have about 1.3 bacterial cells but still
if your body were a democracy you might
be voted out of power raphael cheerio
okay
who needs a fecal transplant rafael we
just met first of all what we call it is
a fecal microbiota transplant and what
that means is yes we are taking fecal
content from person a and putting it in
person b but this is not something most
of you need which is a good thing for
you to hear it's typically used for
people who have a very severely damaged
environment in their colon one situation
is people who have cetaphicalitis
where their gut has pretty much been
overrun by this bacteria called c
difficile and so in those cases we have
to transport a whole new population of
healthy bacteria from a healthy person
into their gut there are many ways we
put it in through a colonoscope or
sometimes do a nasal gastric tube but
one way or the other we get that healthy
poop into the colon to help it feeling
better just to let you know again
there's this whole thing called the gut
microbiome and so we're not just
transferring poop for poop sake we're
transferring a healthy community of
healthy bacteria from one person to the
other we have this entire amazing
universe that exists inside of us that
can keep us healthy and some people need
a little help from their friends to get
through some situations
fran dreschler could there be a
connection between your gut microbiome
and alzheimer's that's a great question
fran it's one that we're closely looking
into what we do know is that a healthy
gut microbiome produces nutrients that
are important for a healthy brain
omega-3s polyphenols are all very
important for proper neuron formation
and function in your brain and so it's
very possible that having a very healthy
gut leads to a very healthy thought
process in terms of how to actually make
that work what to do about that
information that we're still working on
the answer to camiate the worst thing
about being a woman bloating why must
the air in my stomach feel like 10 000
knives women frequently can have
hormonal effects that come from the
uterus come from the ovary and affect
the gut dynamics and so sometimes you
have aspects of the gut that are not
relaxing the way they should or that are
not moving your bowels along the way
they should there are many medical
definitions of the word bloating but
typically to be honest we do tend to use
that as a description of the symptom
when it comes to what the underlying
problem is it could be constipation it
could be diarrhea it could be gastritis
what can you do about it modify your
diet so that you can tolerate those
times of the month a little better there
are many conditions that can have the
symptom of bloating and cause people to
feel like they're having a thousand
knives shooting through their guts all
right angry angry alice asks what is
constipation if not clogged farteries
all right alice uh you're creating a
whole new terminology here constipation
is essentially when your bowels are not
emptying out as routinely as they should
in a way that they should and so there's
this component of frequency and then
there's this component of a subjective
description of how your bowel movements
are and how you feel with it so you
should be moving your bowels at least
three times a week anything less than
that is formally constipation if you
start it off however is moving your
bowels daily and then you drop down to
four times a week that might be
constipation for you that change in
bowel movements rsb 90. i know bananas
are a good prebiotic but what else is
i've started on probiotic tablets for
gut health so probiotics are bacteria
that exist
that we intentionally sometimes consume
they come in pill form with the concept
of trying to put healthy bacteria into
our body i will say that not everyone
needs to take probiotics if you have a
healthy diverse diet that could actually
give you the probiotics you need just
from your consumption alone so if you're
having your kimchi and kombucha and
yogurts that may be all you need
probiotics essentially eat prebiotics
and what are prebiotics in shorthand
those are essentially fibers they're
things that probiotics like to eat so
that they can increase the number a
healthy diverse diet will contain all
the pre and probiotics you need to be
healthy yourself cookie for you and me
that's nice my poop is black am i dying
okay i hope not and odds are you're not
dying but yes black stool can be very
important what cookie is referring to is
the fact that black stool often refers
to blood in the stool blood of course
starts off as being red by the time it
goes to the digestive process and gets
all the way down to the toilet bowl it's
often seen as being black and tarry and
so if you notice that change in your
bowel movements that might mean that you
have an important gastrointestinal bleed
going on other reasons for having black
poop it might be food coloring it might
be licorice it might be pepto-bismol but
typically it's not something you want to
see and if you have that very important
to talk to your doctor about ian hammond
asks why does coffee make me poop all
right we know not to hang around you
right after your cup of java there are
many reasons why coffee might be making
you poop one of them is that coffee in
general can cause peristalsis in the
colon so that's that p word again it
just means it makes your colon move the
poop another thing that coffee can
sometimes do through caffeine is relax
the anal sphincter making poop more
ready to come out of your body and
sometimes it's just having a warm liquid
and the routine of it all something
entering your stomach that really more
than anything else is just a trigger of
that gastrocolic reflux for things to
start moving along conor leary 64. does
my ibs cause my anxiety or does my
anxiety cause my ibs
question asked for billions of years and
the answer is
yes so for the uninitiated the lucky
ones of those of you who are ibs stands
for irritable bowel syndrome it really
just means that your gut is irritated
and hyperactive and very sensitive to
any amount of distension in your gut
causing a lot of pain a lot of gassiness
and either a lot of pooping or a
decreased amount of bowel movements your
ibs does cause your anxiety often in the
form of a person having severe symptoms
and not having a clear answer as to why
they're having symptoms additionally we
do find that people who have anxiety or
depression have a higher likelihood of
having irritable bowel syndrome work out
frolic how does gut health impact your
immune system so it turns out that in
your gut again we have this microbiome
and that's the word that just keeps
coming up that's intimately involved in
the function of our immune system it's
important to note that your immune
system 70 of it exists within your
digestive health
tract having a healthy diet for your
microbiome keeps your immune system
healthy as well it's able to produce
short chain fatty acids that keep your
colon cells very healthy and robust and
all of this leads towards a healthy
immune system and a healthy you that's
it that's all our questions from today
hopefully you learned something i know i
did i learned about farteries and i will
see you next time bye
[Music]